Speaker 1: Let's go next to where are we
going next? It's not clear. Let's go to J.T.
from South Carolina. J.T., you're on the air.
Hello, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Oh, nice to meet you,
David. Likewise. Long time. I'm a long
time watcher. Just want to know, have you
recently been seeing the things circulating on
social media regarding trapped African exchange
students in Ukraine and the treatment they've
been facing from the the authorities there?
Speaker 1: I have seen it and there there were
some incorrect reports about what was going on.
And some good reporting as well.
I have not read anything about it
in the last three or four days. Is there something
in particular going on now that I've maybe missed?
Speaker 2: Well, no. It's just I'm calling from
South Carolina and I've been talking with a lot
of people in my community and, you know,
the black community and how they how do you
basically perceive this whole situation? And
I find that a lot of people in my community,
and I'm not by no means speaking for everyone
in my community, just the people I've personally
spoken with. I find out a lot of them have a hard
time garnering sympathy for the Ukrainians because
that's all you see on social media nowadays,
with the Ukrainians being under constant threat
from the Russians, how United States is sending
billions over there in aid and how the media is
shining this light on this humanitarian crisis,
which I agree it's terrible, is going on.
Yet we all aren't shining the same light on people
suffering in South American countries or in in
African countries that are facing similar threats.
Speaker 1: I mean, yeah, you know, that's that's
always an issue. And here's the thing, JT, you
know, we I've talked on my program endlessly about
why, what determines what makes the news and what
doesn't. And there's all these different factors.
And one of those factors is certainly who is it
that is being oppressed? That's a factor. One
hundred percent. That's a factor. What is that?
What is the profile of the people being oppressed?
Other factors include Is it an oppression that
has a clear beginning, middle and end? And this
is why sometimes long term suffering gets less
attention than an individual crisis that's like,
OK, Russia is about to invade. They've invaded.
There's now an invasion. And in principle,
at some point that invasion will stop. That also
is a reason why certain things get more attention
and other things get less attention. So I think
those are all legitimate things to talk about.
It doesn't justify in any way what Russia is doing
and the value in repelling the invasion. So yeah,
I mean, I totally get what you're saying.
Speaker 2: Thank you. Thank you. And one
final thing I want to point out is this is as
if the Republicans have had a whole 180 about
the immigration status of the Ukraine. They want
to bring a lot of Ukrainians over here. Yet we
just expelled over 4000 Haitians just last year.
Speaker 1: I know here, I know the if you want to
find hypocrisy and fickleness, look at American
immigration policy. That is without a doubt that
you can always count on that.
Speaker 2: Oh, well, thank you,
my friend for taking my question. I'm finally glad
I finally go on the show. I appreciate it so much.
Speaker 1: JT, it's been a pleasure.
Thank you. Thank you. All right,
there's JT from South Carolina making
a number of different important points.